[Music]
big eyes is directed by Tim Burton and
stars Amy Adams and Christoph Waltz and
please excuse my incredibly awesome
Dragon Ball Z hoodie this was a gift to
me today yes I am doing all these
reviews and seeing all these movies on
Christmas Day cause you know what it's
my passion I love it a dude for you guys
and doesn't even feel like work
sometimes in all honesty busy yes work
no this movies a true story of a painter
played by Amy Adams who painted all
these big eyed children she became very
famous for doing that except her husband
played by Christoph Waltz is actually
the person who took all the fame and all
the credit because he said that he
painted all of those so for years this
poor woman turned out hundreds of
paintings and copies of paintings all in
her husband's name without getting any
credit for herself one of the reasons I
was really excited to see this movie is
because it's actually a real movie
directed by Tim Burton it's not some
whimsical fantasy movie or you know some
thing with Johnny Depp in white
facepaint it's actually a movie and so I
was like whoa Tim Burton is being really
restrained and that's one of the things
I love about this movie Tim Burton
really pulled off a fantastically
directed and restrained movie in which
you could really tell the Tim Burton was
like look I'm just gonna make this movie
you know I'm not gonna do any crazy
stuffs not gonna have Helena
bonham-carter
it's not gonna have Johnny Depp it's not
gonna have any crazy face makeup it's
just gonna be a straight-up movie and
even though there are like moments where
you can feel a little bit of whimsical
fantasy throughout there it's so limited
this feels just like a locked-down movie
directed by Tim Burton and he did a
great job it's actually one of his best
movies in years probably maybe his best
movie since big fish and Amy Adams was
absolutely luminous in this role she was
strong she was beautiful she brought
this incredible feminine urgency to her
character that really just made you want
to just get in the screen and punch
Christoph Waltz in the face because you
realize that a lot of this happened it's
honestly one of the worst things you can
do to someone emotionally is to take
credit for someone else's art and I
really connected with that aspect of Amy
Adams character and she was magnificent
in this movie and I loved a lot of the
dialogue about finding your own
inspiration
the back-and-forth between her and
Christoph Waltz especially because it
gets deep and dark eventually it gets to
a point where you're like wow can this
man get any more maniacal and speaking
of Christoph Waltz I think that for the
most part he's great in this movie there
are some parts though where he gets
really over the top to the point where
he gets a little cartoony now I don't
know if I can critique that though
because the real-life woman is still
alive
so it is entirely possible that she
described the way her husband acted and
that Christoph Waltz did it perfectly
but in the movie he does feel a little
bit larger than life a little bit bigger
than he should be from time to time
there are moments in the movie where it
does drag a bit though and a lot of that
is due to the fact that the movie
doesn't fully explore some of its deeper
questions in the way that it could that
combined with Christoph Waltz being a
little over the top from time to time
makes the movie not as good as it could
be I did think it was a lot of fun and
one of Burton's best in years and I
loved seeing him do a very restrained
movie and Amy Adams is truly
oscar-worthy in this movie she's
absolutely magnificent is is not an
Oscar Beatty performance this is truly a
good work and I think she's great in it
I'm gonna give bigeyes a B+ I do think
it's a very good movie and I think
especially artists of any kind will find
a lot of things to appreciate about this
movie I saw another movie today the
imitation game I'm going to have a
review for that coming very soon guys as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]
Oh